how's it my name's agatha and so far
we've seen what 7-elevens look like in
asia and we're pretty familiar with what
they look like on the us mainland
and i say mayman because i'm right in
honolulu hawaii
now our 7-elevens are by no means
full-on cafes here but here
the food is a little different so
today's challenge is to eat a
seven-course
meal from 7-eleven hawaii mascot babes
we're going shopping
[Music]
all right now we are back home and i'm
pretty excited to try some
food usually when i go i just usually
get the same stuff so this will be also
a taste test
as much as a journey as it is for you
guys back home
even though i'm from here so let's get
right into it
whenever you go to 7-eleven you get a
slurpee um this used to be a slurpee
so apparently the flavor for this is
leahey gummy
it basically tastes like yellow gummy
bears mixed them with some orange or
white gummy bear
i like it usually i'm not a big fan of
li hing like li moi
it's like this tangy plum all right for
the first meal i got
simon simon i feel like such a staple
like even the mcdonald's here have
simon smells good oh that's really good
this is actually quite nice there's bits
of some charsoo in here egg some green
onion
and then it's just a soup base this is
your classic salmon
and then you got spicy aji on top of
inari so the anatomy is a little bit
difficult to eat especially if you have
a topped
with spicy eye it's a bit messy
oh rush welcome well you can definitely
tell that the spicy ahi was
previously frozen next up is the spicy
akilo
pull it out and you envelop it
and there you go the ahi
and rice ratios throwing me off a little
bit all right next up in this course
oh it's so cute
you can definitely see some of the bean
in here
it's not like gushing out but it's got
like a sweet bean
kind of flavor the moshi self pillowy
squishy part
that bit is very soft and what i like is
that it doesn't get stuck to your mouth
and then last in the fit of the course
taro manju it smells like peanut butter
like the outside bit like a nutter
butter so it looks like
that it has like something in the middle
like the filling
filling that's gonna fall apart
oh the outside portion is very ready
like a loaf
but it's cakey these are definitely one
of those like pastry things you need to
drink with otherwise maybe after the
second or third one you're gonna get a
little sick of it oh god
oh on to the next course got a bento
this is a pretty common bento here in
hawaii like different types of meats all
in one go okay this is the fish
that's topped with mushash spam is a
staple here in hawaii at least
almost every household has a can of spam
you got chicken oh here's the beef it's
kind of lumped in there
and you almost always see these super
good it's like pickly
not like green pickles i think that's
just like too much fried stuff for
me and then we got kimchi it tastes like
any kind of kimchi
yeah it's not bad i started eating
kimchi when i was like four i think
getting to my favorite item out of
everything i bought today poor cash
but this is shrimp pork cash and i like
it because it's the most convenient dim
sum
that you can get i got some shoyu show
you soy sauce
that is home right there i'm gonna
polish this off later
and then kind of add a little crunch to
this segment
mixed when you lick it it has like that
shoyu like caramel sweet
salty taste when you bite into it i'm
not convinced
they're basically like crackers they
just have like a thin layer of coating
outside
for course three i got kahlua pork and
laulau lalo is basically usually there's
pork
um and it's wrapped within tarot and tea
leaves i've never had it from 7-eleven
and was actually
vacuum sealed when i first got it in the
container and then you get to
a meat essentially there's a lot of bits
of fat in there
yep this is like a whole chunk of fat i
did not
have a good experience with eating pork
fat as a kid
i will be opting out
i like it's cool a port that is quite
nice actually as for like the
this bit itself it's a little on the
bland side but i mean it's still good
it's still soft
what's next spam must be i think every
person
here in hawaii has at least tried as
families to be at least
once sometimes you know there will be
egg in between
there's a home right here too um i feel
like 7-elevens here in hawaii are a
little bit more asian influence
let me try the layered coconut pudding
and taro dessert
think of you know like jello when you
first bite into it but it's
almost ready so now we are going to do
the inside meta which basically is
a sugar coated butter roll
our oh that's a lot of butter and sugar
though there's no filling inside but
it's okay
we're not picky this is the kind of food
that's going to make me break out
i turned 24 this year and i still feel
like
i haven't left puberty i already
finished three courses
now we got four more next on the list
so a locomoco is basically like a mix
you've got your
rice egg beef patty and then you got
gravy
that's not bad you know what this
reminds me of salisbury steak with the
gravy
like from the lean cuisines next on the
list
we got amanapua specifically charsu um
look at that and that is why
you never play with your food folks this
pool is pretty flat
my opinion of these do not get them from
the refrigerated section
get them actually steamed when it's
still hot like by where the cashews are
at
it's a little bit more puffy and it's
warm of course so it tastes better
moving on to the next thing we got some
ube
products i said ube because that is
literally what the brand is called
they're like little tarts
not cookies but they're like
they're soft cookies oh my god
oh it smells so nice so if you guys
don't know what ube is it's from the
philippines essentially
ube comes from purple yams yams are kind
of similar to potatoes
if anything so technically this
is a vegetable
oh damn oh my god oh this is so
good i'm going to save this for when i
can eat more unattractively now we're
going to try the tarts
holy crap so they're ube cheesecake
tarts it has that you know the pastry
layer
that nice soft cheesecake this is all
going to expand inside of me
and i'm going to expand right with it
next round
i think this is the fifth round and
you've got another bento but this one
is teriyaki chicken bento so you got a
teriyaki you got your little yellow
pickle thing again and then you also got
a hot dog
no photocopying on the rice but it's
okay
i kind of don't like it so far i think
the meat itself is what kind of threw me
off it's not
tougher and you got the hot dog and we
also got
ika but it's tegu style it's like some
type of pickled sweet
it's not that spicy really you just like
you feel like a hint of it it's kind of
like eating sriracha which is really
mild so i see bits of
garlic no this is sesame alright second
to last meal
we have got when i was younger i had no
idea
pho was pronounced fa i used to
pronounce it as faux i like
that that they have green onions they
have i think this is mint you got
beef and then you've got of course your
onions okay what i like about this fuzz
so far
it tastes quite similar to the ones i've
had at restaurants before i definitely
have a critique about this
the meat is really tough let me try the
soup
i think the soup base doesn't have a lot
of depth into it kind of top off
this course this is a toy doughnut and i
believe this is also poi donut but with
matcha
first off this is a lot different from
what i've tried like the texture is a
little bit different on the inside from
what i'm used to there's like this
softer
less bready texture now on our final
course
we are going to just kind of go all ham
on the desserts basically we got toki
supposedly exclusive from korea
into our 7-elevens it's a little sweet
it's like a corn chip and then for the
ice cream
try the kulolo i've never seen this
until like literally today
it's mainly taro and coconut this but an
ice cream form
it was like tiny grains not like sand
it's got like a coconutty
milky fresh flavor then we got
some manco it's like you know those ice
cream cones you buy from like a store
this is literally it ice cream itself is
your usual vanilla ice cream and got a
light colored strawberry syrup
and then last is our samurais hawaiian
frost this is just strawberry and
vanilla
this stuff is so good it's like icy ice
cream
there's not too much cream i think i'm
pow so hawaii's got at least over
60 something locations a lot of them are
on oahu which is the island that i'm on
there's a bunch more products than the
ones that i showed you guys here on this
table
i would definitely recommend for you
guys to check out our 7-elevens when
it's a lot more safer to come visit and
travel of course
and i had a really fun time checking
this out so thanks to buzzfeed
for letting me spend some of your money
i'm a little full but i'm not full
but i feel like i'm gonna have a canac
attack so
no i'm just gonna keep eating